fresh Russian attacks are being reported
in Ukraine following massive gains by
Kiev in the east of the country Russian
missiles damaged a reservoir near
president zielinski's Hometown the
Central City of kriviri putting one of
Ukraine's largest urban areas at risk of
flooding as acts have also been reported
in the east of the country in the
khakave region where Ukrainian forces
have pushed back the Russian army
president zielinski's visited one of the
liberated towns in a show of defiance
but alongside the celebrations evidence
is emerging of alleged atrocities
committed during the Russian occupation
in the city of izume President zielinski
shakes the hand of a Ukrainian Commander
thanks to his troops hard work the city
has now been liberated from Russian
forces
but there's been so much fighting here
that there's not much of it left
[Music]
there are no surprises it's you know
that it that's not shock for me
the view is very shocking but it's not
shock for me because we we began to see
the same
pictures from butcher from the first the
occupied territories so the same
destroyed buildings killed people and so
what can I say Ukraine's Northeastern
counter-offensive has seen the Ukrainian
army take back a wide swathe of
territory in a space of just a few days
but residents here are shell-shocked
what they endured during six months of
Russian occupation is just starting to
come to light
in the battle scarred city of balaclia
southeast of khakive reports of torture
are emerging
they made me hold two wires attached to
an electric generator the faster you
spin the higher the voltage they kept
spinning it and asking questions
they said I was lying so they did it
more
it happened to some prisoners every
other day
with the Ukrainian Army back in control
residents here long to put the dark days
of War behind them
and see the Ukrainian flag rise over the
country once again
Emmanuel Shaz in Ukraine's Second City
harkiv in the east of the country where
Ukrainian forces are continuing to
consolidate their control in parts of
the region
welcome Emmanuel good to have you with
us let's start with the overnight
missile strikes in khakifa
yes well at around midnight here hark if
time we heard an explosion and a missile
hit not far from here in the city center
a few kilometers away from where we are
it was probably launched not too far
away from here because the air defense
system the air Red Alert didn't start
beforehand we heard the sirens howling
afterwards obviously everybody who could
took shelter for the next the next hour
this morning hotkey for authorities said
that there was no casualty following
this strike and also that there was no
damage caused but this is a daily
occurrence here in eastern Northeastern
Ukraine day in day out the shedding
continues here in hark if we are only 35
kilometers away from the Russian border
and more accusations of Russian attacks
on civilian infrastructure with an
attack on President zelenski's hometown
exactly yeah
for Cleveland which is in central
Ukraine which used to be the biggest
city in central Ukraine pre-war there
was a 650
000 inhabitants there it is President
zelenski's native city as well it was
hit as well by eight uh missiles so a
strike on its water power plant
infrastructure a dam was damaged or
Reservoir was damaged incurring the
water to rise for for to up to 2.5
meters and this actually corroborates
what the Ukrainian authorities have been
accusing the Russian army of doing of
hitting civilian infrastructures here in
the Northeast we also experienced a
power blackouts quite regularly because
power plants are being hit so we do see
a pattern there to cause maximal damage
that will affect the population
and what can you tell us about these
reports of the president being involved
in a car crash
yes last night there were some reports
emerging a
Kiev apparently the incident is not too
serious you know the Ukrainian president
always traveled with Medics as well he
was immediately taken care of he doesn't
sustain serious injuries and his driver
was immediately brought to hospital for
further attention but apparently not a
serious car crash accident okay thank
you for that Emmanuel Emmanuel shares in
harkive